my name is ghilane Maxwell pronouns day
then get it right
I met Jeffrey at a torture convention in
Vegas and we was asking the man what
happens if you put somebody in a little
room for a long period of time but no
lie and he said sometimes they just come
out of the room and they just start
sucking people off
we was best mates me and Jeffrey really
we would go everywhere all over the
globe you know finding you know kids to
hell I said to Jeff II the first time I
met him I say is your country run by
satanic vampires and he said yes I said
mine too
we could have had a laugh about it but
then we came up with a business you know
we was in the fantasy business it's what
we did really so if you had a fantasy no
matter how [ __ ] weird it was we would
make it happen you say oh right I wanna
[ __ ] two twins and then push them off a
roof all right I want to [ __ ] somebody
on a boat and then blow their brains out
as I'm coming come on in
it's like a microwave for billionaires
really that was part of what it was sex
work is empowering at any age that's
what people don't realize I like
California I feel very home in Los
Angeles because people here aren't super
judgmental I've been offered really five
or six jobs in the last couple of days
just you know it networks and studios
they sort of like my style they want to
keep me off the box sort of quiet life
but they like my organizational
capabilities that's at least what the
email said or said to Jeffrey one time
we was on the beach when I looked at him
and I said one day all of this is going
to come out and people are gonna murder
us and now is that day like that's what
it is a lot in an out burgerbob of
chick-fil-a because a lot that they're
committed to religion you know we never
had any on our own I mean everybody
black girls just not into it really
they're very loud you're cool they're
all like oh I supposed to [ __ ] you know